well let's jump into this first story
which will kick things off we have this
from timcast.com and it says Victor bout
warns Trump of assassination threat from
the Biden Administration quote they
would sooner end your life than let you
stand in their way okay now I'll just
stress The Merchant of death as they
call him claiming that the bite
Administration is even considering this
is just hearsay coming from a guy who is
an arms dealer who is Russian so I'm not
saying which necessarily trust him I
just think the general idea is
interesting that this guy is basically
calling on Trump here's what he said
quote therefore I think it's in the
interests of all of humanity and
primarily of the American people to
invite Donald Trump here to Russia to
give him security and protection here so
that he leads this Uprising against the
globalists and most importantly does not
allow the elimination of the American
people
I just think it's a particularly bold
and I don't know kind of creepy story as
it were but I do think that in this vein
we are we are staring at the potential
for world war three if if we're not
already in it Russia wants to put
nuclear weapons in Belarus the U.S is
providing arms intelligence and you know
I'll say this they're indirectly the
United States indirectly has individuals
on the ground volunteers who are
fighting the Russians I think that
whether or not his sentiment is correct
we are facing some kind of very serious
International conflict so I'm curious Dr
Paul your thoughts on everything that's
been going on with that well I have made
up my mind whether or not when people
talk about World War III and most people
uh think in their mind about World War
one and World War II is a certain type
of war tanks and bombs and airplanes and
all that and I can't quite visualize
that I think the world has changed too
much matter of fact politics has changed
a whole lot as well but I I've
concentrated more recently on thinking
about how to how do revolutions come
about have their changes been made have
we had a World War III to do it and I'm
arguing the case that uh we're in the
middle of it and moving right along that
that the revolution has been fought and
it is uh you know there's been a coup
that take a we don't have any
resemblance to a government that
believes in a republic we don't have
honest money we don't have integrity we
don't even have people in Washington
that even pretends you know that you're
supposed to tell the truth you know
remembers just recently there was a
congressperson that won and he he won by
putting on his resume just a bunch of
lies and and the other one's got
hysterical the other congressman is
telling lies like this and I got to
thinking well how many of these people
that were complaining about this guy
telling lies how many of them lied when
they raised their hand up and swerved
uphold the Constitution now that's a lie
that really has consequences actually
you could probably make fun and make a
little joke because his jokes weren't
everybody knew he was fibbing but the
Real Lies are being told and and that is
our big problem but I do believe there
has been a coup and it's been taken over
and if I want to if I can I want to just
put the date in my mind and you anybody
could pick probably any date in the last
Hunter a year but I picked uh I have
picked November 22nd 1963. what happened
on that day that was the day Kennedy was
murdered by our government wow you know
by the CIA and at the time I remember I
was in a matter of fact Kennedy uh was
killed in uh in in Dallas but he landed
at Kelly Air Force Base and I was a
flight surgeon there the day before and
I was aware of this TR of this trip so
this was this was a a big deal the a big
thing and those early years which we
talked about a lot especially the first
year or two oh Roswell did it Oswald did
it and then and you know the person they
they talk about most is uh uh it's uh
Alan Dulles as being the instigator of
all this and he uh guess what to LBJ
immediately say we have to investigate
this this president has been
assassinated what what they never use
the word coup so he's been assassinated
so I I guess he puts there were seven on
a commission and uh uh and Dallas you
know Dallas was put on the committee to
investigate it so but he was going to
make sure they told the truth it was a
big Force but that was a big day in
history in my mind yeah that was the
beginning of the Hostile takeover of the
American government by the spy agencies
that of course have been becoming more
powerful less unaccountable by every
decade they've been doing more crazier
things and then we came to Iran Contra
they've been getting away with so many
crazy things they've never never been
held accountable and for every decade
it's like oh yes the last decade the CIA
did something really horrible that but
they but they were never held
accountable for it but they're
definitely not doing it now but well
they are but I I thought you were going
to say 1913.
well I think that was the groundwork I I
start the uh intellectual change is a
little bit before 1913 probably at the
turn of the century uh you know the
Roosevelt era and the university started
teaching progressivism and gradually
they destroyed the whole principle of uh
like today in medicine there's no such
thing as truth anymore and this is this
Society has become nihilistic because
they can do anything they want and they
have a zero guilt they have no shame
because uh they don't believe they don't
believe there is such a thing as true
and uh even both religious and
non-religious people sort of come around
to agreeing you know a society would do
better if one if they had one rule don't
don't commit violence against anybody
else you know when it isn't that
complicated it's basically the
Constitution goes along with that but
not many people take that seriously and
but no I think 1913 was a consequence of
what was happening in the universities
and the universities are still in bad
shape but the real education that is
going on now is continuing especially in
economics and and other things I mean
there's there's a Institute now dealing
only with non-intervention and foreign
policy you take a group like The mises
Institute they've done a world of good
at teaching young people and I still
rely on them to understand uh you know
free market economics so that is where
the real change is and uh you know I
have I'm a fan of homeschooling and
homeschooling can be a Salvation too and
I happen to have a little program for
that but that the private schools we
still they're still legal in the 1980s
early 1980s there was such an effort to
close down every private school
conceivable in you know the record cases
that in spite of how bad things were
they recovered from that and but that
doesn't make me complacent to think they
won't touch us again in private
education because they will because when
they see that that the people who
telling the truth of the real enemies
and that's what's going on in politics
can I I'm curious your thoughts on
Donald Trump as a candidate as a
president
is he running again yeah
well I I don't think a lot about it uh I
I think politicians are pretty much
irrelevant
you know uh they're they they reflect
what's going on and uh but I I think the
least important thing well I can't say
that every single thing I did was not
related to politics because I
concentrated on one philosophic issue
and maybe made a little impression and
that was uh what sound money is all
about and uh talking about art the FED
prior to 1976 when I first went to
Washington the Federal Reserve was never
talked about and they thought boy people
would come up to me and what do you what
are you talking about them for you know
it'd be wonderful so I think that uh but
I really do believe that the politicians
just reflect a prevailing attitude of
the opinions of the people very very
important so what I saw is dramatic and
wonderful was during the lockdowns that
when crowds finally said enough is
enough and they started to rebel against
that stuff so it wasn't it wasn't a
dictatorship of the majority in a
political sense it was the people got
disgusted and they woke up and you had
Parents waking up but they're ruining
our kids you know and they were they
would go to parent PTA meetings and fire
some of those people so I think attitude
is a very important education is very
important so that's why right now I
probably spend
90 percent of my time trying to
understand and pass a message on to
others the reason why I asked about
Trump is because you said just a moment
ago that you think the change the
Revolution was nine was it 1963 I think
you said 63. oh no the the beginning the
coup that was 62. 62 sorry I got the
wrong uh I'm you know based this the
story we pulled up and you have this
Russian arms dealer saying Trump's at
risk I'm wondering if you think there's
any uh validity to that what was that
again the Russian arms dealer claiming
that Trump's life is at risk because
he's trying to stop globalists I'm
wondering if you think that's absurd uh
well to me that come across with that is
I probably don't know enough about it to
be really astute about it but it seems
so superficial you know I'm more into
Marxism and why marxists are nihilists
and why the the whether that's uh the
original marxists or the culture
marxists of today that their main goal
since they don't have to worry about
truth and honesty their main goal is is
chaos Street chaos riots and you don't
have to go very far to to look around
for what's going on their goal is uh and
so I I still struggle with it why they
do this it's so stupid and so harmful
the only real explanation it isn't it
isn't stupidity it's done on purpose
because chaos leads to the breakdown of
order and uh that's that is our real
real threat but it originated I think
back even before 1913 it's just that
then it actually it was uh 1960
three I'd say that that assassination
was a big thing that same decade Martin
Luther King and RFK
and over a hundred people that were
loosely associated with Kennedy that
they they suddenly died nobody knows
exactly which ones were related or what
but there there's some noise out there
that uh really indicates that it was a
big big event wow Bobby Kennedy Malcolm
X as well I was I was wondering what do
you think about uh another Kennedy
running for the presidency and that's
Robert Kennedy Jr uh are you guys
excited about uh him potentially running
yeah because he announced we talk about
it it
we talk about about it and he's a friend
and he came out to one of one of our
anti-war conferences and people loved
him and I think I think it's great uh
that he's running but uh it's it's not
likely I mean I'd have him on my program
if he would come on but I I probably am
not into the endorsing business you know
because because I think as very
secondary to waking up to people I want
the people to wake up about the monetary
issue which we're going to have the
opportunity because this monetary system
is just starting to crack and then the
people wake up just like they got sick
of sick and tired of the lockdown and I
talk about the football game that I
don't remember where it was but there
were a hundred thousand people showed up
and they didn't wear masks and that was
sort of the Breakthrough I thought that
was fantastic the people will wake up
and that's that's what I figure that I
can contribute to wake people up thanks
for watching this clip from the Tim last
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time